Shaquille O'Neal the hall of famer turn
to Sports NBA analyst inside the NBA on
TNT and you can check out the big
podcast with Shaq at podcast one.com
Shaq how are you today
I was looking for the motor is working
fine it's redacted though so when you
get the molar report I don't know if
you're gonna see any names in there that
means the names are blacked out so you
won't be able to see names in the molar
report
[Laughter]
hey I stumbled upon something this
morning and I ride up the troops here I
was talking about how great James Harden
is I think he's underrated I think that
now I'm just talking about offense and
and I know you hadn't done anything the
postseason I think James Harden is a
more all-around greater offensive player
than Kobe Bryant and Michael Jordan
you're thought you stopped it wait we
have to listen okay
Michael Jordan played in the toughest
era you still do what you did meet Kobe
and I played down in a watered version
arrow that these guys you can't
handshake and do anything of course it's
gonna get over that that type of
offensive to you nothing against James
Harden here's a great plan but I think
we need to start we need to start
breaking breaking up players down by
arrows so just say he's the greatest
offensive player in the world and he
didn't have to go do stuff that Michael
Jordan and Jerry West and all these guys
don't think it's unfair to guys like
that I could go fight against bad boys
in one Michael Jordan play where where
you don't think to pick a person back
and we're fighting for one now you know
now you now you touch the people to go
to a desk for five minutes and look at
the pain and then it calls a caucus
doing it the game is long so but but
then I love you but you might be wrong
on me they love him back me up
you know I got you chef but my point is
check the way James Harden beats you is
he's the most versatile he can shoot the
three he can shoot mid-range he can get
to the hoop he can dunk on you
he draws fouls I just think as an Jordan
and Kobe you know unstoppable but harden
beats you he can score on you in
different ways now I know the game is
different but I'm gonna give you two
names okay
and Derek all with the hands yet the
rule allows you to hold a desk they was
gonna direct you the way they wanted you
to go so now the question is if we still
had those rules in place would he be
able to do that I don't know I'll just
say well I think Harden is mastered the
current rules I think we can both agree
on that right yes all day every day to
play I've seen a long time but you just
said two basketball gods he's not there
yet implicitly he's got to have
postseason success as well and I think
that's really what's the the glaring
omission from his his resume as harden
hasn't done well in the postseason why
is that right I don't know maybe over
you you know there's always the saying
you live - unity there but it takes a
lot of threes so no and then you know
this agent he's been playing well and
putting up big numbers my fear is that
he may get tired then be you know longer
this thing's over doesn't happen I want
them to have great success but we shall
see and that's why you know the playoffs
are always exciting that you never know
what you're gonna get have we seen the
likes of Zion Williamson before in the
NBA of course
you don't Bron James yeah
Robert tractor-trailer Charles Barkley
yeah we have how successful do you think
Zions going to be because you mentioned
those guys and some guys were successful
and some guys weren't it's hard to tell
t67 among six seven guys we have our
guards he can shoot a little bit I
really haven't seen him do a lot of
polls and he gets to the team at that
run run he's gonna do very well but you
know the policies when in certain games
you gotta you know slow it down and you
know take advantage of mash up smallest
I would somewhere as well just do with
teen drivers and little coaching them
but you know on the brakes on the
prairies freakish a free and he doesn't
gonna be the dumb one bit however just a
name I haven't been hearing and I should
be had Bobo lookout for Bobo this kid
can do it all
okay if you hand the number one pick
well if I have someone pick up i'ma go
with new nose I on you know but I'm this
you know putting on those all your other
NBA teams yeah
ball boulders mobile is great country
square out difference and he has a
jumper Bobo and I've been knowing this
kid a coach from women watching him play
but I don't know how like Tokyo today
he's got more stuff than even I seen him
do is LeBron good you join you guys on
inside the NBA I saw where Abbar CLE was
asking pleading if LeBron wanted to join
you is that gonna happen
I was surprised I think that Charles
never got a number then you and Charles
disagreed on the Joelle embiid elbow to
Jared
Ellen's jaw I I agreed I I said flagrant
two III I would if I were said thanks
any amount to normal tell you have to
turn to shoot so if your head is in the
way you get hit doesn't mean I threw the
elbow just cuz you get hit right think
about that
McLovin I have to say you know when you
were showing Berkeley how that elmo
worked when you were showing her I was
thinking I could have been the guy that
could have been the the foil to you
instead of Berkeley I was a skeptic of
that no yeah would you when you saw it
you can tell the difference between
turnings and you know turning into
contact and throwing at the contact so
you know a lot of times when you're
Karen and you know guys heads instead
he's gonna get hit but it's big bags we
got talk to talk to turn with the voice
got little guys reaching you know you
got you know defenders that found a
blocking shock to terrible force okay
but Jo Ellen Beach reaction JoEllen
beads reaction postgame is the reason
why I thought he did that with intent
because you know Jared Allen is a guy
who wants to block your shot and AM bead
you know gave him a little bit more
emphasis there and then he laughed about
it where he was like he felt bad but he
started giggling so that meant that made
him guilty oh you have to know you have
to know him in bed and I very well after
that because when be said he was already
been was like you're not really sorry
and you're not because as a big guy when
I turn whoever gives me taking a hit I'm
not sorry I'm done playing aggressive
you know if you know in the poll you got
to move out the way you know I'm not
going to limit the way after example
miiverse dikembe and in the finals
yeah every time I turn I'm trying I'm
trying to get some off balance
can't block my shot you got to do it and
I'm turning with force so if I hit him
in the chest he's gonna bounce back
complete like the videos that they all
show and then they'll probably call
wanted to I doubt they get me for six
offers of else
I'm turning what force and he gets it
just a picture of the beach talking of
Shaquille O'Neal did you ever feel bad
when you hit somebody
no you ever just runs somebody over for
the heck of it yes who stands out that
they they took the full brunt of you it
was just kids playing for the Hawks and
he just kept getting on my skin so I
tired missed him with the elbow he was
on me but I was all bad and I fell right
on his face as he got the file and he
never played me like that again because
you know because you know just kept
letting him get away with stuff I said
okay
of course this guy can't guard me you
know I'm turning around
I'm actually trying to be nice up she
didn't turn around jump folks he's all
the malls or if I can call it this
torture chamber time how would you been
as a boxer boxing MMA how would you do
how would you do in the Octagon I'd be
violent
my private I probably have trouble
wrestling or kick him cuz I have bad
shows but must stand up you know as soon
as I actually asked and I said Dana if
you ever send word or celebrity UFC I'm
in who would you want to fight me I
don't want to say his name because he's
gonna respond I'm gonna have to beat him
up I see it play baseball and Custer
fired you know well it just
Canseco my glove and most won't talking
about but they're loving those will talk
about I got to visit Jose Canseco
McLovin is that a we're not gonna say it
out because he's gonna get on the
Twitter I'm sorry I crazy
yeah I got one
slurps how about the mountain from Game
of Thrones
I don't know everybody's you know tell
me problems I said he's a big guy so I'm
allowed to decline he's about your size
not as good post moat moves as you but
he he might be the strongest man in the
world Christian people with his hands
yeah like you used to
that'd be great though yeah but you
don't want to fight Jose Canseco yeah
you know just be like you know like you
know some fun thing
hey nothing first of all I'm not you
know just playing just joking around
hey Charles yesterday said that he had
the Blazers winning the West
Mojo's I was talking about I was
surprised I said I'd take the Rockets
he's got the blade nobody's beating
Golden State huh oh no oh they're not
they're not
hello how would your Laker team do your
best Laker team do against Golden State
a fish was talking about this the other
that Derek Fisher yeah which one you
pick I'm gonna go with the best like a
team effort to 101 1501 okay that's
another discussion it could happen any
time we are the best collective team in
the players ever
I don't care who played before me I'll
go play out to me that team right there
17:01 we share 160 well anyway if I was
interrupted by McLovin Leslie would you
be golden citrus of course you want your
Fisher and ok question number 2 which
rules are we play over there are rules
in all today's rules it will be tough
because you can't touch people up but I
wanna instructor Derek Fisher let them
drive a couple times staff so and I'll
touch them up so we have their staff and
their staff for probably I'll do that
now to Kobe and Katy you can even go
either way but I'm not gonna say call
the ask a deal-killer corner down at the
attack or $2.00 for response could stay
with klay Thompson horrors go ahead or
team where was the holy spirit if it's
your team 16 I don't I can't remember
everybody the horse ran into him on like
horse brand of course house it'll start
be Bogut I don't think so I do not think
so and when Steve goes small who's
guarding me nobody so we wouldn't sweep
them but I think it's fair to say that
we will beat them and then I heard them
say that they will beat us and that's
what convocation is all about and I
really love and hating his conversation
because we will never know of course
everybody's gone oh we do this we do
that but we'll never know it's always
fun to think about those thing I mean
that's that's we love these arguments
because there is no right or wrong
answer goes right do you play golf no
hey Mark mark please never had to you
Alan the golf course oh well actually
versus we bet 50,000 that I will be
delivered eight and a cake in against
him and Bobo Watson and we beat up you
can look it up McClelland right along
with us I had a 45-foot putt to be
talked about nine holes 50,000 went
right through the room got the money I
can verify it was a but thank you to the
hell of a bug because I was out there
with the caddy and you know always go
over like putt putt so I'm gonna add a
hole I'm trying to hit a straight to
cause back
she filled it to the right no Mike what
trust me I did this name shot this
morning here to the right and I hidden
to the right and that thing won't happen
I just curves know how and when an older
one that's the first shot I love you all
you do that 10 times it's 50,000 more
it's great to talk to you as always the
big podcast with Shaq at podcast one
common of course inside the NBA
a Turner coverage of the NBA continues
throughout the clamps Shaq thank you for
joining us thank you
McClellan I'm sending them my divorce
papers you only said five words to me
this is ludicrous well yeah because you
don't watch Game of Thrones we have
nothing to talk about anymore Shaq you
gotta watch Game of Thrones well I watch
season one there you go
I love Khaleesi and we'll catch up on it
when we go on vacation after the season
together our families writes a check for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on be our live or download the
Dan Patrick show app